he's one of the stars of the new film 12
strong about the Declassified true story
of the first American soldiers sent into
Afghanistan after 9/11 he is Rob Riggle
good to see you sir good to see you
I also don't wanna I mean I mentioned
you're you're the man on Fox NFL Sunday
with your skit in your prognostication
portions on that show I gotta write
yesterday so you did I love your spots
in Modern Family - man thanks when you
show up in that Gil Thorpe as GILF the
biggest jerk in the world yes the the
man that you don't want to see when
you're trying to sell a house pretty
much or buy one as well good to see you
in other words thank you so so what do
you think of the games yesterday what'd
you think of those games yesterday yeah
they kind of unfolded like I thought
they would except for the blowout I had
no I can see that coming I I thought it
would be much tighter I actually thought
the Vikings might you know they but I
did say this to a friend of mine I said
I go I think they all their magic was
spent against New Orleans and you come
off an emotional thing like that I know
they're professionals and I know that
they could rebound and they do what they
got to do and prepare but that was one
of the most iconic things we're ever
gonna see in a professional football
it's up there with the Immaculate
reception I agree it's another version
of the Immaculate reception and so
that's gonna be a lifetime clip that
we'll all be watching and that you saw
how they went nuts and it was so I think
it's hard to come back from something
like that I know especially with the
pressure as well I guess there's your
your point there they're professional
athletes they deal with pressure that
they could have brought the Super Bowl
to their house I know they went down
they want so bad so bad yeah you know
they're filling up the Mall of America
on a Friday doing the skull chant oh and
then of course the Eagles fans doing the
skull chant themselves but saying foals
instead of skull yeah I don't know how
that's gonna play when those Eagles fans
roll in to Minneapolis I I don't think
they pretty thought that very well
they're gonna have to coat the entire
town with Crisco but I had reservations
I don't see him sir no I have a room I
months in advance no it's funny how it
doesn't dynasty I got lots of room for
these Patriots fans true
you never know now
singly enough I received a text last
night shortly after the NFC Championship
game ended by someone that you know very
well I a fan of the Chiefs I did mention
the show that you were in with him on
occasion in Modern Family
you share a charity with him in the
Kansas City area I know who you're
talking like his name reminds me iran's
with Eric Stonestreet pointing out that
the Chiefs beat both of the teams that
are in the Super Bowl this year that's
just a stone-cold fact that's not even
debatable we're not there's no talking
about that that's just a lock so so deal
with it
Eagles fans and Patriots by the way in
back-to-back weeks to start the season
I mean weeks one and two took care of
them well that's how you announce your
presence with authority and of course
then I don't want to talk about the rest
we came out hot didn't only five and oh
man those were magic days it weeks one
and two feel like 10 years ago done it
though it really does it does it really
does back when Alex Smith was an MVP
candidate Kareem hunt was an MVP
candidate which was the coach of the
year yes and you know I'm obviously a
rabid Chiefs fan this year so obviously
I made a meal out of those first five
weeks on Fox yes and really played it up
and then I had to go radio silent for
like the next seven weeks it's you know
cut like a knife I don't blame you yeah
and then we rallied and I thought to
myself all right this is not bad because
we are getting our mojo back we're
getting back on a winning track where
we're doing things it's coming around
and we're gonna peak right as we hit the
playoffs and it dreams gonna be
fulfilled the circle will be complete
and my mothership can come pick me up
again and it didn't know it did
unbelievable and as a Chiefs fan my son
and I he's a young nine year old who's
new to the ways new to the force oh and
I it was 21 3 at halftime and he goes
let's go play your game is locked and I
go son
let me explain she won't see we're not
going anywhere until this thing is
and there that was a hard day oh that
was a heart I am a gence Oh rob riggle
here on the Rich Eisen show so is this
ripe for NFL honors comedy or is it cut
too close to the bone look you know
thank you
I've had a couple weeks to digest to
digest and process cauterize put things
that comprises the right word stop the
bleeding start the breathing these are
always the procedures right and so I did
those things yes and yes I imagine
there'll be a yuck or to throw now so
what is who is do you believe somebody
again who has been following the NFL as
close as you have and also making it
funnies but for Fox who is right for
comedy the most in the NFL what do you
think you who you at this point in time
a few Saturday to Saturday's it's going
down who are you who are you targeting I
mean there's there's it's a target-rich
environment you've got of course the
commissioner mr. Goodell mm-hmm who I
think he could always use a couple shots
okay like people are gonna say the
Browns are low-hanging fruit you know
leave them alone really Oh a sixteen I'm
not leaving him alone they kept their
coach didn't they they did they kept
Owen 16 he has a job and now I kind of
understand we need to get some
continuity we need to you know you can't
just fire everybody every year yeah okay
is it Owen 16 and and one in 31 over the
span of two oh come on
this is crazy the people of Cleveland
deserve better and said of course it's
hanging Louis you're gonna pick it I
want yeah I don't know McAdoo I know
he's gone but he was just a wonderful
just the visual of McAdoo back when he
had the slicked yeah then he changed up
his look then he had the pornstache he
was just so poor McAdoo is gonna be
sitting at home the night before the
Super Bowl turn on the TV and he's gonna
go he'll have a big thing of popcorn
yeah and he'll be so stoked for the NFL
on
no I try not to be too much I don't like
I don't like the bullies no no no but
you do have to point out what's in the
room sure No so you got to have some fun
and the Commissioner is one of them as
well okay I think for sure okay yeah all
right well you know tread lightly to use
the Breaking Bad term absolutely on that
front
it's a tricky front cuz what I did I was
a great sense of humor he does but does
not you know I'm much of an opportunity
were the Commissioner of the NFL there's
not a lot of Gatineau you're yucking it
up you gotta go to if you're the
commissioner your average become target
you're everybody starting correct you
don't have any friends this is kind of
sucks it's a very lonely job I imagine
yeah I'm looking forward to getting out
there and having fun I do realize you
know when I hosted the ESPYs that you
know sometimes the athletes aren't all
they're not fun in games you know they
take themselves very seriously oh my
gosh and I'm like it's just uh we're
having some fun tonight guys the SOI
when you say tread lightly I'm like yeah
no I'm telling you I you know when you
watch say Kim will do his his opening
monologue at the Oscars or something you
could see sometimes they're kind of
don't find it very funny I'm sitting in
the it was just tight everybody's tight
athletes are worse yes I really believe
that yes although I I was at the ESPYs
when Will Ferrell came out as Harry
Caray and went through a bit of a bunch
of lines that got nixed by ESPN
management just went out and did it
anyway I'm making fun oh it's good to be
Will Ferrell he made fun of well I mean
he wasn't Will Ferrell at the time he's
Harry Carey no no he was what I'm saying
he was he was just just a very famous
guy on Saturday Night Live that was it
he had not gone stratosphere
right he hadn't gone stratosphere yet
and he made fun of John Elway's teeth
just again to give you an idea of who
was in the audience
oh and John doesn't like anything about
John apparently so keep that in mind if
Elwes in the audience where he might be
yes he said something about ken griffey
jr. wasn't as good as his dad I'm
telling you do you think like that means
that that's nothing right yeah he
not happy yeahit's they're a tight crew
athletes are tight they're wrapped
really tight and then you put them in an
environment that is not their elements
mm-hmm you know like the court the field
the diamond you know that's their
element and then you put them in a
tuxedo sitting there while someone look
at this look as ridiculous I was about
to say something I shouldn't I said hey
look at this guy yeah and they don't
like it because they've lost control of
the situation and and the different is
laughing and they don't know if it's at
me or should I laugh along or no I hate
this guy oh and the director knows the
joke about them is coming so they can go
it's right me up oh they zoom right and
then they give you game face they don't
give you laughter they give you game
face well although Anthony Davis I give
him a lot of credit because I threw out
a something about his because his team
beat my Jayhawks in the finals that year
okay the year I do the SP so I was not
happy with him so I said something about
his eye eyebrows looking like two
caterpillars about to make love or curse
you no problem yeah and they cut to him
and he was dying laughing
and I was like now there's there's a guy
who gets it he's in he's fun thank
goodness he's very tall man as well very
tall man probably what happened this
year do people think what up with Durant
I forget that joke where they where was
it Peyton Manning made fun of Durant and
they zoomed in on Durant and he did not
laugh at all everybody wondered was he
in on the joke or was he not was about
joining a team to win a championship
right yeah yeah yeah that was a big
thing yeah it's a tough crowd they're
always tough anytime you get in front of
athletes they're tough crowds but it's
great for you to do it because not only
you funny but you also get the NFL you
know it and you're also a host who's
like okay I want to know what the MVP is
I want never losing the Pro Football
Hall of Fame it's gonna be a big night
yeah I'm a fan I'm a huge huge fan so I
just consider myself very lucky to get
to do it and then I hope you know I'm a
good advocate for everybody at home that
wants to do it there you go
fantastic Rob Riggle we're gonna come
back in 60 seconds and talk about 12
strong because you play in this film
your former commanding officer yeah max
Bowers that's right you play him and so
this is a a film that's very near and
dear to you for a good reason because I
mean
you damn near live this old turn
yourself right okay no these guys okay
rob riggle when we come back here on the
Rich Eisen show talking 12 strong and
more in 60 seconds
[Music]
all right before we get to 12 strong
with you rob riggle you have the joke
that Peyton Manning dropped on Kevin
Durant yeah yeah Peyton was like you
know the u.s. women's gymnastics team is
just one gold medal dummy
they're so dominant that Kevin Durant is
considering signing with them and he
didn't he wasn't I love it I think it's
a good one
and it's fair yeah but there was a talk
that he was in on it they let him know
right
hey this is confident I'm telling you
ESPN they know how these athletes can
gradually goes for such you know tough
guy that's right it's really interesting
so let's talk 12 strong again it's in
theaters near you it opened up on Friday
for those who may not know what is your
history with the Armed Forces well 23
years in the Marines retired in 2013
served in Liberia Kosovo and Afghanistan
worked down at Ground Zero in New York
on the rubble piles in the bucket
brigades moving rebel by hand but the 12
strong story is a great story it's a
true story
based on the Army Special Forces guys
that win in right after 9/11 so the
story takes place in October of 2001
these are the first guys boots on the
ground they teamed up with the Northern
Alliance 12 of them and the norm lions
only had a couple hundred and we were
they took on close to 50,000 Taliban and
al Qaeda fighters and beat them drove
him all the way back and through and out
of mazar-e-sharif and allowed us to get
a foothold in northern Afghanistan and
and really prosecute the war from there
and eventually drive drive them out
amazing story now I after I was Ground
Zero I volunteered to go back on active
duty I was a captain at the time had a
pretty high security clearance for my
job so I knew they would be looking for
folks like me so I volunteered that sure
enough Central Command picked me up on
November 10th which is the Marine Corps
Birthday November 17th I reported a
central command November 30th I was in
Afghanistan and when I got there I
reported to
Lieutenant Colonel max Bowers who was
the commanding officer of 3rd battalion
5th Special Forces Group and I just
worked on his command element his staff
i briefed him every morning brief from
every evening you know did civil affairs
and public affairs work for him and now
I'm playing him in the movie Wow
so it's very small you know it's a very
small world in a very surreal thing
because I do have a connection I knew
these guys I lived in mazar-e-sharif
with them and got to know some of the
guys on the on the different teams and
so I felt a direct connection to these
guys
so do you do you believe you have some
of the mannerisms of Mack yeah did you
did you nail it I'd say yeah I think I
did all right I think I was very true to
the man right now I hadn't talked to
Colonel Bowers since Afghanistan I
didn't talk to him before the movie I
didn't talk to him during production all
at all so I aware that you were playing
I don't know I don't know but the
premiere just happened yeah the movie
just came out this past weekend and
through channels I got his email so just
yesterday I wrote him an email and said
hey sir yeah well I still even though I
retired a lieutenant colonel and he did
too so we're both lieutenant colonel
okay to me he's still sir cuz that you
know I'm not sure sir I said hey sir I
you know I hope you saw the movie I hope
you I hope we did your story justice you
and your men because what you did is
will go down in military history as one
of the greatest feats blah blah blah
blah and I just you know a little
personal note back and forth and then he
wrote me back so I so just last night I
got an email from him and it was very
nice email oh good so and he was happy
and pleased and he he remembered some
things because again personal notes but
it was great it was it was neat so I
finally just said last night connected
with them two enthusiastic thumbs up yes
yes amendment you reply exactly he
thought he thought we did an excellent
job
Rob Riggle here on the Rich Eisen show
now where were you in your career oh no
we were and the rubble I had done
nothing of the Twin Towers I had done
nothing I was at the UCB theater Upright
Citizens Brigade theater in New York
doing one am improv jams for nine drunks
in the audience
I was doing sketch shows I was doing
anything I could do to get stage time
really but I was down to the UCB
basically doing comedy they're pursuing
it that way are you the only marine that
you know of that's gone into comedy I
mean you know I don't know again if it's
led or something recently I'm the most
recent okay probably but there's like I
mean there's great Marines that have
gone on to show business comedy wise
drew Carey he was a staff sergeant in
the Marine Corps I did not know that
yeah you all see his picture you'd be
like dang he's a motivated tough looking
marine right there uh-huh you know
Harvey Keitel gene Hackman Lee Marvin
Captain Kangaroo was a Marine now what
was his rank though was he did he
promote himself to captains that's one
way to do it the only way I was ever
gonna make full Colonels if I became
Colonel Sanders which I did let's be
honest so I guess the only I'm just
trying to think where you were you a
private Joker for a lack of a better
phrase when you were in the Marine Corps
were you crackin wise or no I mean
here's the thing it's weird you know I
was an officer and I didn't I never
wanted to be a goofball you know you
kind of want to instill confidence in
your Marines yeah especially if you're
in a combat zone or in harm's way or you
know any of those bad places so I never
really was a jackass but I never changed
my personality either you know what I
mean I was true to myself I mean if
something's funny I would crack wise
then but for the most part I tried to
keep two hats one comedy had one marine
hat sure 12 strong again in theaters
near you check it out before I let you
go let's talk charity big slick in
Kansas City you're always the best about
that thank you feeling come on know what
you guys do in Kansas City for
Children's Mercy Hospital
is second to none you raise seven
figures in one event every year and that
you it's the you guys as you and David
Koechner and Paul Rudd and Eric
Stonestreet and Jason's today cuz it's
primarily all from Kansas City we're all
sitting and it's a family event like
Jason's mom provide she's a travel
agency handles travel Gloria read Paul's
mom she works in PR so she kind of does
all the marketing and public relations
my sister and brother-in-law kind of
handled the operations Dave Koechner
sister handles a lot of the hotels and
the merchandising and the coordination
with the different elements that we do
and a Stonestreet sister works as a
liaison with the hospital directly so we
actually when we go visit the hospitals
and do all that stuff so it is it's a
true family grassroots effort and you
know like you said we raise a lot of
money you've been and we've always
grateful I love it and you know and when
you talk about Brock when I I've always
sung the praises of this channel
well now reason cuz you Sarah Tiana your
girlfriend does a podcast on podcast one
with with Rob correct and you were kind
enough to guest on the one if Susie and
I have we're kind enough that and what
we'll come back and we'll do a home at
home yeah but at any rate because so
many of these charity events they are
they can they're fun okay I understand
that we have fun but when we're out
singing karaoke after midnight or so you
and Koechner and all the other guys come
walking up to us and you tap the watches
and go we're going to see you go see the
kids we're gonna see in the hospital
morning so get your shut-eye the marine
comes out you're a grown man so if you
don't want to do it that's fine I'll
still be knocking on Eugene I know and
we go and the kids and just it's it's
truly amazing work that they do at
Children's Mercy do they do incredible
things that's how they got me I I went
and saw them to open our surgery on a
nine day old baby we're just a year
prior that baby probably wouldn't have
lived and so that you saw like within a
year that's the kind of advances in
technology
that's when I'm a parent I was like well
you I'm in I'm in you got me so that's
when we started you know the the thing
and it's called the big slate cuz it
originally started as a poker tournament
balling now it's bowling hmm
but we also still play a softball game
at Royals at the K Kauffman Stadium I
still I call a royal stade when I was
due but and and and then just real quick
before I let you go they take me out to
the ball game moment seventh inning the
Royals always let you and the rest of
the crew go out there now the whole all
the big slickers go out everybody goes
out everybody goes out and we sing and
we've seen the take me out of the
ballpark and we always end it with Gene
Lamont which means nothing to anybody
other than the first year we did the big
slick Will Ferrell was there we were
sitting in the dugout suite and we were
heckling Gene Lamont he was a third-base
coach for the Tigers and he just
happened to be close and he was on the
other team so he got that he got the
wrath and it was a lotta that's
bush-league call come on Lamont and it
was just the Lamont was such an easy
name to yell and it was so much fun
whose that's bush league Lamont
come on even though he was doing it I
did nothing I don't even know if you
heard us because we were in his hip
pocket just yelling at him the whole
game and so then it just Lamont Gene
Lamont became this thing that's how you
every time you walk out to the from the
dugout to the third base we go Gene
Lamont Gene Lamont Gene Lamont like the
death star that's great and I don't know
it just became this thing in the more
beers we had the better funnier was to
us so and now who's in now she was a
member of the Royals front office Gene
Lamont have you told him this story yeah
I think he's heard through the grapevine
but the bottom line is welcome gene
please forgive us
big slick kc.org to find out more about
that at Rob Riggle on Twitter at big
slick KC on Twitter of the podcast with
Sarah Tiana checked that out and 12
strong in theaters near you and we'll
see you in Minneapolis for the NFL
honors day at all
Rob Riggle here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience